crypto it's what we always knew it's
just a Ponzi scheme it's technology
it's what we always do
it
we buy into Ponzi schemes all the time
we do it all the time because we're
greedy and we just want to make sure we
go we get there before the rugs pulled
out but like the thing about that yeah
yeah no it's a fact everybody wants in
on the Ponzi scheme you just want don't
want to be left with the bill right but
everybody wants it everybody wanted in
with Madoff you don't think these people
knew they're not dumb like they all knew
buddy buddy they all have access to the
same tools right for their trades every
one of these hedge funds have access to
the same tools and finally there's no
way that Bernie Madoff and three other
people like have found some crazy new
way to make 15 every single year they
know there's some wild [ __ ] going on
they don't know it's necessarily a Ponzi
scheme like that but they know there's
some corruption going on they're like
listen oh
you handle the biz to pay me my [ __ ]
money that's what it was they might have
known some [ __ ] going on but I don't
think they thought it was an actual
nobody's team in their monies it wasn't
that extreme but nobody was surprised
something illegal happened oh yeah right
they were just surprised they lost all
their money yeah but they knew that
something illegal is happening right so
I just say the same thing with crypto
it's just like this is the thing that I
was I watched this video and they said
this brilliantly it's like you know how
they're like crypto it's going to
replace the Internet it's a new thing
it's like crypto's been around for what
13 years yeah probably okay when the
internet was around for 13 years what
could you do with it you could do emails
you could look up the [ __ ] weather
you could transfer information like
you've never had before four of their
websites with actual there's actual
things built on the internet that were
utilized by us to improve our lives
crypto's been around for 13 years
nothing's happened
I had a single thing has happened
besides other ways to create Ponzi
schemes so it goes Bitcoin right then it
goes okay anybody can make a coin after
ethereum comes out and use ethereum's
blockchain to create your coins so now
everybody just creates a coin some more
Ponzi schemes and then they go okay fine
they're realizing that their policies
came nfts they pivot the embassies uh
newly Ponzi scheme enough teams are done
web three uh let's sell land that
doesn't existence it's just new Ponzi
schemes over and they're gonna come for
you for this problem
The Matrix and I knew it from the
beginning I was like it's just Ponzi
schemes but I I did and I was I lost the
most
[Laughter]
I'll buy it from you like I can't just
sell it because you know we're making
content
so anyway so look anytime if you're
willing to buy my original prices I'll
sell to you but if not you no so
the point about the crypto thing is all
it is is one Ponzi scheme after another
and it's so funny and it's good Ponzi
schemes have existed forever we're gonna
keep on making them it is what it is but
you think they'd make like one piece of
technology that like offered utility
like even like the smart contracts right
they're like oh it's gonna replace
contracts you don't even need lawyers
anymore it's like no you [ __ ] do
[ __ ] you need a judge to look at the
contract and look what both sides signed
up for and see if one side was violated
or the other side was violated you still
need a human to look at it this contract
at the block that's on the blockchain
isn't going to do anything to stop that
it's a Ponzi scheme now
no I I would say nobody ever I don't
think anybody ever said crypto would
replace the internet if literally was
the marketing for every single this is
this is more impactful than the
invention of the internet this is the
new web impactful than the invention of
the internet I don't agree with but it's
not replacing the internet well web3 is
supposed to replace the internet web3
okay which is yeah okay I guess that's
okay fair that's what you're saying now
but I just thought Bitcoin could replace
money and I still think a universal
currency could happen especially if we
go metaverse and live online and all
that [ __ ] but I don't think it's not
decentralized also the wealth of crypto
is more centralized than any money that
exists on the planet right now the
amount of people like you can actually
look at the amount of people that are
holding Bitcoin there's nothing
decentralized about there's like 10
[ __ ] people the mining is not
decentralized half of it happens in
China half it happens in El Salvador
it's like the biggest [ __ ] lie has
been told to us and because we were
making a little money we're like I'm not
gonna look at any of that [ __ ] but we
all knew it you could very well be right
I'm pushing back based on what I'm
hearing but I'm not going to act like I
know the most I assume they mean there's
no what is it IMF or whatever the what's
the International Bank that's what
they're saying when they say
decentralized there's not people who can
just come [ __ ] with the value and
inflate it and deflate it however they
can't make more whenever they want to
well they can depending on the coin with
Bitcoin but but with the other ones yeah
with the other ones absolutely yeah yeah
100 we bought into all that I'm not
saying Bitcoin is the best can just make
it disappear yeah that's true
as soon as this guy gets on YouTube it's
all right if you get a good documentary
shows his hand oh you are you are famous
tomorrow you're gonna be famous
watches your documentary thank you yo
that's my boy he's fired yeah see now
yeah
that's just inspired yo it was Danny
brilliant James he's got amazing ones
he's like it's a great second
I actually know it that's hilarious
that's my tape
whatever that [ __ ] says is true
I believe anything James daddy says
because I already agree with it okay so
once you satisfy the feelings I already
have you're brilliant that's how people
work you didn't know that's how people
was if I feel something and then you
tell me a smart way about how I'm brave
[Laughter]
let me say this let me say this he's
right to believe because I'll say this
because another wave of the greed will
happen what I'm saying is eventually
you're gonna have to get out it doesn't
have to be this wave or the next wave or
10 waves yeah right but there's
eventually there's going to be time
where you have to get out we gotta get
you a documentary bro
if you even look at all the propaganda
in the language it's brilliant like the
language is all propaganda and the
people don't even realize it they go
Diamond hands huddle or whatever like
that hold on for dear life right like
all these all these terms are used to
keep to trick you into keeping your
money in the coin so these other people
that are waiting to rug pull can inflate
it enough so they can get their [ __ ] out
immediately it's just genius and then
people identify with the terms like oh
dude you have paper hands you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
give me paper hands I've wished my hands
made of paper these diamonds
those are not Diamond heads you don't
know how to get in your phone
you don't know the password first of all
they are diamond hands because diamonds
have no real value either okay
I already did
so yeah it's just again this I think
that you will make money I generally
think you will just think stuff isn't
worth as much as we think it is it
genuinely does not no no it would be the
narrator of this part put it this way
put it this way I think that there will
be another opportunity for you to make
money whether he takes his money out or
not yeah and really happy for him when
he makes all that money well here's the
other thing about it
because he's going to be bad wait he's
making money
this is the trickiest thing this is the
new flying cars
yes
Dylan he's a villain I'm sorry to all
the all people that lost money with him
he is the most evil person on the planet
to the people who never invested in
crypto and saw idiots get smart and
they're not sorry and so idiots get rich
for no reason he's a hero
he's a hero yeah the majority of people
I mean this is really the majority
people saw Sam Baker free loses 40
billion dollars worth of crypto and they
go
nobody feels bad yes about anybody that
loses money gambling and crypto's
gambling yeah so nobody feels that the
tragedy is there's like guys like
[ __ ] through his entire [ __ ] life
savings into FTX thinking that it was
his one opportunity to make money like
serious money in his life for his
retirement that's [ __ ] tragic we
never think of those people we think
about some [ __ ] guy he's still in his
basement
no no
Alex has gold on his teeth bro his teeth
are full of gold he's like man he's poor
broke [ __ ]
so those people stuff but nobody
identifies those people as the investors
of
crypto they think about the crypto
billionaires listen here's the reality
when it comes to this is reality when it
comes to life in general
if your friends who have never made
money in their life I know which friend
you're talking about specifically it's
not me it's you no if you're friends
you've never made a friend way more Rich
that started way more broke if you're
friends who have never hey shots buddy
if your friends who have never made
money in their life yeah
start making money based on a thing it's
[ __ ] he's still mad
we might remember we started patreon for
a reason
yeah one Bitcoin remember where you were
it's not like you were flushed with
[ __ ] money okay this is my Bitcoin
say again this is my Bitcoin what is
this podcast
this podcast is real
thing that we like work and like make
money yeah
that is a tangible I look like a board
eight but I'm not yeah so the point is
the point is if any like the point of
this out he goes he had all this people
that were making tons of money on
mortgages in around 2007. all of his
friends his [ __ ] dumb friends who
didn't even [ __ ] graduate college
making all this money and [ __ ]
mortgages [ __ ] idiots baboons making
money and [ __ ] mortgages yeah once
you see your friends making money and
mortgages immediately go
do you remember this we're in a [ __ ]
hotel in Arizona we're in the pool and
there's these like five British people
no teeth talking about like yeah we just
you know we travel all over the world
but we made all this money in crypto and
they were like trying to hustle us into
crypto do you remember this at the pool
and they were like these like
Hillbillies yeah they're Hillbillies
from England and they were like yeah you
know we've been doing crypto we've been
selling and try yesterday it's the
future broth like literally no teeth
like their tongue was like hanging out
no that's just British yeah yeah I guess
probably yeah and I was looking at this
and I was like oh yeah this is good it's
like a year and a half ago I was like
yeah this is not good can I say the
other one that's about to go oh yeah
please
um
everybody's making money in real estate
now right
every [ __ ] idiot every [ __ ] idiot
is making money real estate right now
right every every New York apartment's
going for five million [ __ ] dollars
this house over here is going for 20
million tell me
it's going down
it's going down
okay if your friend's wife never had a
job in her life is making money in real
estate and it's going down
bad